I'm dead
oh my God I'm Not Dead
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the returned bloody
nights there's a payday to be had I've
already gotten paid maybe I did I don't
even know if I did but I imagine there's
a little more story to uncover
and that is the entire cast I've already
forgotten how to play so I assume that
I'm gonna die a lot really quickly oh
God we're back
all right
hello
is this thing even working I don't know
oh yes hello it's waffle brogie here I
had bad news here there's a there was a
terrible accident with one of our
employees and another Pizzeria
what's that damn yellow suit based on
Spring lock technology
it's called some real trouble
uh We've made the decision to stop using
the costumes
together
one more incident like this and our
business is ruined
now listen carefully I need you to meet
me in the morning after your shift we'll
record new instruction tapes to send out
to the other restaurants that have these
costumes and I'll explain exactly what
you need to do again simple as last time
you know what I have a theory that
someone may be sabotaging the
functionality of these costumes on
purpose it's a real shame too they used
to be one of our biggest draws we'll get
to the bottom of this whoever's
responsible will be held
but enough about that
let's talk about you
what about congratulations on making it
tonight six oh Jesus
I've got your payment ready and waiting
for you maybe in the morning and we'll
settle up until then keep an eye on
those animatronics you never know what
they might do
especially now
good luck and I'll see you soon okay I'm
already in trouble like I'm already in
trouble it's already bad oh good though
I'm dead I'm never gonna be able to get
the heat down
oh God you're not even there
oh god oh goodness gracious
I don't know what to think
that's not good oh you are so active
everyone is so active and you still
haven't paid me oh I'm boned oh wait
what how oh God
well I'm dead so just kill me because I
wasn't even aware of what I was supposed
to
well this is going to be tricky okay so
the the thing that I gotta not die to
all the time is Mr peek-a-boo Mr
peekaboo
really loves to show up at inopportune
times
whoa what the hell
oh wow
wow oh hi Mr Peek-a-boo I was just
talking about you
oh my God
how is this Fair the door has to be
closed like all the time
how
uh
oh my god of course
I don't know I don't know I don't know
get your butt over here
oh my God
how is that even possible how do you
how do you do that you know who I
haven't died to is Mr groans a lot
Mr left ear groans a lot do I need to
keep it closed for the entire time that
Mr groans a lot is there
or is it just the last moments
because he waits at the door a very long
time I'm wondering if the game actually
wants me to balance that because if that
is the case then that would give me a
little more flexibility than having to
have that closed all the time I mean you
guys might have told me thus or maybe
you didn't I don't really know
so he's at the door
but I don't know look it just doesn't
feel right
and I know it's probably fine well
that's a problem
uh well
okay but that has to be it right so it's
got to be some kind of an internal clock
of thinking of when the left door would
need to be closed and really only
closing it when he is close on the right
that's the only variables here that I
think could possibly be the way that I
could beat this otherwise it's next to
Impossible if it's not that you know
what I mean
that's gotta be it that's gotta be it
boss yeah that's gotta be it
that's got to be
[Music]
yeah you're there
but that's okay
you're fine
you can open
now you can close that's gotta be it
that is definitely it
is there and that's fine
I've got all the time in the world
so much time
[Music]
I feel bad
was that him
oh my God I timed that well way too
close but I did time that
you're there now
good there
damn it wow man I'm too much too much
leeway
damn it
[Music]
oh my god well I'm boned
frick
but it's better so I can keep this up
and now there's a chance there wasn't a
chance before because I definitely
wasn't doing it right but now I know so
as soon as I do that I'm going to count
to ten that's probably how much time I
have maybe a little too much to be
honest but this is what I gotta go with
you can do almost all these just by
sound and flashlight you don't have to
go to the camera as much as you might
think and in a lot of ways it's
sometimes better to just do it by
flashlight because there's certain
threats like Mr endoskeleton over there
that are worrisome the only one that
really needs to be seen is peekaboo
all right
I don't know what that means what does
cupcake mean
I don't like Rogue variables
ten
seven
oh six
I hate it
good okay I've got time
got time
check the bride okay close that okay
okay that ice probably still had more
time
I've got so much more time than I think
I do
oh no no
I've never died to him oh
who's the door he's got some time don't
be crazy survive the night on his
Darkness will be your final deal or his
Darkness will be okay okay so I've got
some time I was right about that he says
I've never died to him before but I got
it I've got like 10 full seconds
ten big in seconds
where did you come from I didn't even
see him on the camera
oh God whoop
[Music]
ah I had time on the one to the
left
well interesting whoa God damn it I
forget when you flip behind the sounds
flip the source of the sounds flip
I just have to remember that
just wait on it wait on it open up this
one balls of steel
balls of steel oh my God balls of steel
holy crap balls of steel
okay
wait which side was that
oh my god oh
I I keep forgetting that I'm giving
myself more time and therefore he will
go away quicker
okay it's fine oh my God it's fine holy
it's fine it's fine God it's not
fine oh cool
come on
Frick I am not doing great
I didn't hear a dong
oh my god when did you get back
oh man
Frick this guy
I'm dead
oh my God I'm Not Dead
fine
you need to be better about opening them
and hope that I won't be caught unawares
hurry up
3am
not doing great
but it has been worse
okay
I have to do that because Freddy is
there
oh my God
you serious oh frick
[Music]
foreign
I gotta let it cool for a good bit after
that that was too much
okay well I say that
I won't be able to Will I
[Music]
don't know okay you're not alone I know
I'm not
you you think I don't know that I'm not
alone here
[Music]
oh my God I cut that one well
oh
I thought
oh God no no my chance come on
freak
just give it a rest give it a rest give
it a rest
[Music]
fine
I know I could give him more time I just
don't feel comfortable
and also I'm bad
[Music]
two bunks
I love two Bonks
[Music]
you're gonna be right here
okay
all right
I don't know when he appeared
I know I had more time
the Bonk on the right happen
it must have
must have God
oh my God
nothing
I'm not sure if
the cupcake is just a red herring oh my
God
I don't like it
oh man
that was too close
[Music]
probably fine
oh that's bad
it's not the worst thing
not the worst thing
stressful
[Music]
come on
oh my God
holy crap
oh
oh what in the hell is that
[Music]
there was someone that night
I called for help but no one came for me
foreign
[Music]
I can't disappear my
none
I found others who were just like me
they need my help
[Laughter]
save them
I must guide them
thank you
[Music]
I will give them their happiest day
this wasn't the analog or hell
[Music]
the the end
hey dear Scott after recent unexpected
events following the acquisition of our
company by another organization we have
had to change our plans regarding the
future work at one of our establishments
fredbear's Family Diner you've proven
yourself to be of extraordinary value
and we want to offer you a new contract
that are different local establishment
for a day shift job please check your
mailbox and respond to us as quickly as
possible Freddie and his gang are
waiting for you
99 dollars
I thought that was going to be paid so
much more are you kidding me you pay me
99 and gave me coupons to get the rest
anyway missing children
well
well I already saw the credits so did I
unlock any extras and did I unlock any
extra money
no sound oh my God endless no growing
what do you mean growing
oh okay I thought they were
I don't know why but I thought the
animatronics were going to get bigger
that'll be weird six hours oh oh
security puppet instead of adding
difficulty multiply it every time you
get caught
interesting all right well I'm not
interested in those game modes and I'm I
don't want to do a whoa
bears attack great
number eight I'm not doing that Undead
classic
newcomers
no all right let's see what we got in
here
fredbear was the first animatronic that
Henry created great
great
[Applause]
right okay so these were based on the
spring suit ideas and it didn't go so
well
Endo jump scares oh yes please
[Applause]
yes please
[Music]
you know just in case people want to
relive it
laughs
well oh
so there is still the mystery of the the
like analog game that I have not beaten
and honestly
I don't feel like it ah I can actually
see the places oh goodbye oh
oh
uh-huh miscellaneous
outside
huh seems peculiar cutscenes
what do you mean cutscenes
what
that seeds no I don't want them God I
don't want them that badly cut content
let's see what didn't make it okay old
version game
oh that is old office difference
new old new old new old new old is that
money new old new old hmm old new old
new
I don't even know what that is oh that's
a brighter version of the outside I get
it huh
fantastic
oh lovely well done
well that's horrible why is it keep
shaking
oh
spring Bonnie's running
old custom night
wow
oh
game over screen I don't remember there
being a game over screen weird
well it's nice to show these off
well thank you everybody so much for
watching I know that there are more
things in here I'm not gonna go for them
I just I don't have the time to do a
2020 mode on this one and to be
perfectly honest I feel like it would
get extremely difficult because if
Saturday is like even halfway to 20 that
was already tense and already tight
timing there I can't even imagine what
20 would be
and I'm not gonna try it so thank you
everybody so much for all right I'll
I'll pull I'll I'll go into it just to
show you guys that it's probably
terrible which it is absolutely I don't
know what I'm gonna die to first but
it's gonna be bad so I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna go through the trouble of
farming it that's for damn sure
okay how fast are they charging up my
ass
extremely
not that extremely I was thinking they'd
be here already
hello
spooky music I didn't even see the
endoskeleton as an option for difficulty
here I'm not here yet
[Music]
oh you're here
whoa God you're quick
hello what you just
appeared
oh my God
you know what kill me I'm not even
getting into this I'm not getting into
this I'm not getting into this I'm not
kill me
not getting into it I'm not trying it
I'm not doing it you saw how challenging
that was
so thank you everybody so much for
watching great game great Five Nights at
Freddy's fan game check out more Five
Nights at Freddy's stuff in my channel
everywhere all over the place and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]